[Music]
there's been
a tremendous revival of pilgrimage in
recent years
in europe and there's always been lots
of pilgrimages to mecca
to in india in iran there are huge
pilgrimages with millions of people
walking from one shrine to another but
in europe which is very secular part of
the world
um pilgrimage more or less died out
in the 20th century there were still
local pilgrimages in catholic countries
but
um as a huge phenomenon which it is in
many parts of the world
it didn't really exist in in where it
used to in the middle ages
but the revival has been dramatic in
1987 when the
route to santiago de compostela was
reopened with places for pilgrims to
stay
refugios and the infrastructure for
walking there
um 1 000 people walked there in 1987.
it was soon after it had been
reestablished
last year 2019 330
000 people walked to santiago de
compostela
some also went by bicycle and some went
on horseback
so there's been this tremendous growth
and here in britain
the british pilgrimage trust is
reopening
the old way from southampton or
winchester to canterbury 19 days walking
over the south dans and through
extraordinary beautiful scenery and
this year the british pilgrimage trust
launched 42 new one-day pilgrimage
routes
to every one of the cathedrals in
england
when i say new i mean recent
recently reopened i mean these are
ancient sites of pilgrimage
um but they've been re-established and
now you can walk there
and get do five or six mile walk
on a short pilgrimage this is actually a
really nice way of doing a pilgrimage
i myself uh do one of these one day
pilgrimages
every year i have a teenage godson and
when he was 14 i couldn't think
what to give him i don't give stuff
anymore i give experiences and
so because i was interested in
pilgrimage i offered him
um a present her birthday present in
june when his birthday is
of walking together on a pilgrimage to
canterbury
through the fields on footpaths through
meadows
uh through woods and orchards um
to canterbury cathedral i didn't know
whether he'd want to do that or not but
he
loved the idea and we had the most
wonderful day
um we arrived at the theater we let
candles of the shrine of saint thomas
beckett
we had a cream tea and we went to coral
even song this beautiful
song service that happens every day in
the english cathedrals
you don't have to be a paid up
practicing christian to go to this
it's open to everyone and indeed
the british pilgrimage trust when it
leads guided pilgrimages
has as one of its slogans bring your own
beliefs
the people going on these pilgrimages um
are certainly not all
totally devout christians or members of
other religions
a lot of people are agnostic or
spiritual but not religious and i think
it's something that
for many people is a physical expression
of a spiritual quest if you're on a
spiritual journey
then actually making it real by walking
to a holy place is a very very good way
of of doing it so there's a wide range
of choice and
these include pilgrimages to the sources
of rivers
to ancient trees and holy wells
to pre-question holy places and of
course
also to great christian holy places like
medieval churches
ruined monasteries and
cathedrals the basis
of pilgrimage i think is very deep
archetypal i think that's one reason
it's taking off so much in in modern
europe
um the deep archetype i think comes from
the
fact that our ancestors were
hunter-gatherers
hunter-gatherers can't just stay in one
place so
animals don't come to them to be hunted
and fruit and nuts and
and roots and so on don't just drop into
their laps they have to
go around the landscape in accordance
with the changing seasons
as they do so they go to places of
significance with stories and
those are the kind of primal ancestral
holy places they visit
in australia the australian aborigines
sing the stories of these places on
their journey in what are called song
lines
they tell the story they give meaning to
the journey and the places
and they have a history now i think when
the neolithic revolution occurred and
people settled down
in particular places then
they still had this urge to go together
at sacred places stonehenge for example
here in england was not at the center of
a city
like temples where in sumeria and
babylonia and
egypt it wasn't in an urban type setting
rather it was in the middle of the
countryside and people would have had to
go there
for festivals probably at the solstices
and maybe at other times of year
this archetype is found in every
religious tradition
and it's all over the world i lived in
india for seven years where i worked in
a
international agricultural institute
there's a
tremendous amount of pilgrimage in india
there are pilgrimages
among muslims in india many muslims go
to the shrines of sufi saints on
pilgrimages called daggers
and of course one of the pillars of
islam
is to make a pilgrimage to mecca if you
can
jewish people go on pilgrimages to
jerusalem
and in the middle ages the whole of
europe was crisscrossed with
pilgrimage roots here in england by far
the most famous was the
pilgrimage to the shriners and thomas
beckett in canterbury cathedral
and chaucer's book the canterbury tales
uh one of the first books in
recognizable english
tell is about stories the pilgrims told
each other on their journey to
canterbury
they said it was written around 1390.
um another great place of pilgrimage in
england was the shrine of our lady
at wellsingham the black madonna of
wellsingham
the way in which this happened was that
people went on these journeys
they stayed in monasteries on the way
the monasteries provided the
infrastructure the places to sleep and
get food
for pilgrims on their journey but this
came to an end
in england and in other parts of
northern europe
through the protestant reformation the
protestant reformers didn't like
pilgrimage they thought they were too
catholic
um and also the puritans were worried
that
people were having too much of a nice
time on pilgrimages they were fun
um they complained about irregular
sexual activity and so forth
um so uh they
there was a desire to suppress them in
many
protestant countries and that happened
in england in 1538
with thomas cromwell's injunction
against pilgrimage
and at the same time as part of the
reformation here in england the
monasteries
were privatized the monks were driven
out
some were executed um some were just
pensioned off
and the monasteries were closed down all
over england and that destroyed the
infrastructure for pilgrimage similar
things happened in
in northern germany and in scandinavia
in the lutheran
protestant countries of scandinavia
well this suppression of pilgrimage i
think left a kind of vacuum in the soul
of
english people um which
was filled or replaced by
a secularized version of pilgrimage a
few generations later
under the name of tourism the english
invented tourism
first with the grand tour on the
continent which rich young men went on
and this involved visiting the great
sacred places
among other things like you know the
ruins of ancient rome and greece
saint peter's in rome um the great
cathedrals
of europe and so on
so tourism uh then spread
and and became more and more uh
widespread
in in the world um until
it's now or at least until recently
until the covid lockdown was a
multi-billion dollar industry all over
the world
and what do tourists go to do well they
usually go to see
ancient sacred places um terrorists
london visit westminster abbey and st
paul's cathedral
terrorists to you know cologne go to see
the cathedral
terrace to rome go to the vatican and
saint peter's
tourists to egypt go to the ancient
egyptian temples
tourists to india go to the great
temples and great mosques
and great religious tombs like the taj
mahal
so to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or
visit iai.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas